[Music]
hey Disney we've got some questions for
you you're awesome at picking talented
child actors and sometimes it looks like
they have a blast on set she could be
just looking at me and just make me
laugh but what's up with you being
overly controlling when it comes to your
child stars personal lives some of them
have revealed some seriously dark
secrets about what goes on behind the
scenes of a typical sitcom or movie and
what's up with your overly binding
contract we'd really love some answers
Disney it just doesn't seem right I
don't think I was ever really happy with
who I was it's not all fun and games for
Disney Channel actors several former
stars have spoken out about their time
on the channel check out these 10 dark
truths about life as a Disney Channel
star social anxiety it can be a lot of
fun growing up on set but as Cole
Sprouse told ASOS magazine it can also
cause some serious issues he didn't go
to a real school and most of the cast
wasn't his age except for his brother so
he had no idea how to act around kids
his age he developed severe social
anxiety it's why he took a long break
from acting when he went to college took
about a five-year hiatus from acting no
creative input the other Sprouse twin
also had some negative things to say
about working on the Disney Channel it's
safe to say that the sweet life shows
wouldn't have been the same without
Dylan and cold and the twins were 18
years old when suite life on deck ended
but the channel gave them no say in
direction of the show there has to be
another solution their opinions just
didn't matter to Disney according to
Dylan in an interview with vulture
that's the real reason why the Sprouse
twins moved on it's embarrassing Huberty
is a tough time for everyone but can you
imagine going through this as a
celebrity Miley Cyrus has never been shy
about speaking out against Disney she
said it was awful going through puberty
on Hannah Montana when a major personal
event happened everyone on set knew
humiliation in social
death starts properly at 8:01 and she
couldn't even go home to change she had
to be on set to work she was crying and
totally embarrassed poor Miley
cosmetic-surgery Disney Channel once
their stars to be perfect and that means
that they control their appearance when
Demi Lovato was cast on Camp Rock she
had an adorable gap between her two
front teeth Disney Channel told her to
fix it so she did it's just for voice I
just wanted to fit in and be popular it
has to be hard to be told as a kid that
you need to fix your smile she wishes
that she hadn't fixed her teeth because
she thought that the gap was cute she
was young when she agreed to have
cosmetic surgery for Disney forced to
compete it may seem like all Disney
Channel stars are BFFs but that's not
always the case and Bella Thorne told
j14 that sometimes they were forced not
to be friends she and zendaya liked each
other when they were co-stars on shake
it up but they were forced to compete it
was always a question of who was better
and that made things awkward they wanted
to love each other she said but Disney
was relying on their competition for the
show hard to escape Disney Channel has
given a ton of celebrities their big
break and most of the stars are grateful
for it but there's a flip side to that
people will always associate them with
the characters they played as kids
Hilary Duff had a really hard time
breaking out of her lizzie mcguire
persona it just makes me nervous seeing
you guys changing and me staying the
same all the time it took a long time
for people to see her as Hillary instead
but these days she's glad for her time
on the Disney Channel body image issues
every team deals with body image issues
to some degree but Disney Channel stars
struggle with it a lot they're
constantly in the spotlight and Disney
makes them look a certain way Miley
Cyrus has talked openly about how being
told to be skinny and blonde messed with
her self-confidence she had to wear a
wig and a ton of makeup
she wasn't allowed to look like herself
that's probably why she's so big in the
body positivity movement under pressure
being a Disney Channel star is a lot of
pressure your role models for millions
of kids Ross Lynch from Austin and Ally
said that people expect you to always be
the perfect angel that did see makes you
out to be it's the least I could do
after you donated so much money for
Ally's charity he said everyone thinks
that they know the real you
Kieran Brar from Jessie said it's
overwhelming especially once people
start recognizing you that is a lot for
a kid to deal with wardrobe drama Disney
is very controlling of the image their
stars have in public they even regulate
what they can wear Bella Thorne got into
a ton of trouble a few years ago for
wearing a bikini
Disney thought the bikini was too
revealing but Bella's mom is the one who
picked it out if her mom thought it was
okay why didn't Disney they almost fired
her all right they told Bella's mom that
if Ella messed up again they would
terminate her contract
yikes never grow up the Disney Channel's
target audience is children and preteens
they want their stars to feel relatable
but that isn't easy when you're an adult
Joe Jonas has talked about how the
acting he did wasn't appealing to him at
all
it was humor meant for 10 year olds and
he was 20 but that sweater looks like a
peacock threw up on it he wasn't allowed
to have an onscreen kiss they made him
shave every day so he looked 16 he was
glad to be done with the Disney Channel
so he could grow up now that you guys
know how challenging it can be to be a
Disney star would you still become one
if you were given the chance let us know
in the comments thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things
[Music]